afternoon my name's Martin Stone the
chief superintendent responsible for
Cardiff in the Veil
South Wales police is continuing to
investigate a fatal road traffic
collision and serious disorder which
happened in the Ely area of Cardiff last
night
at 603 PM yesterday we received a report
of a serious Collision on Snowden road
which tragically resulted in the deaths
of two teenage boys
the families of the two boys are being
supported by Family liaison officers and
our thoughts are with both families at
this terrible time
an electric bike has been seized from
the scene and inquiries are ongoing to
establish the exact circumstances
we've received CCTV footage that shows a
police vehicle following a bike at just
prior to 6 pm
this footage is being recovered as part
of the investigation and will assist us
in piecing together the circumstances
leading up to the Collision
the families are being kept up to date
we can confirm that the following
investigations have been carried out so
far and when the Collision occurred
there were no police vehicles on Snowden
Road
a police vehicle in Grand Avenue
responded to the report of a collision
attended the area and officers performed
CPR
the investigation has involved the
studying of CCTV and tracking data from
the police vehicle
at this stage we do not believe any
other vehicles were involved
during the disorder 15 officers were
injured requiring medical attention
11 went to hospital and four were
treated at the scene
we were appealing for Witnesses
information and footage from mobile
phones and social media
details on how to submit these can be
found on our website
finally I'd like to acknowledge the
impact last night's disorder had on
local residents who were understandably
very frightened
they have our assurances we will be
doing our best
to arrest all of those responsible
a number of arrests have already been
made and more will follow
we're extremely grateful for the support
from the local community I urge anyone
with information to contact southwest
police
southwest police has also made a
mandatory referral to the independent
office for police conduct to ensure the
matter receives independent scrutiny
thank you
this morning
a relatively short statement from Chief
superintendent Martin Stone of South
Wales police and he was talking about
what you can see on your screen now he
said that they are continuing to
investigate a collision that happened
that resulted in the deaths of two young
men he also then spoke about this
footage and said an electric bike was
seized from the scene and he
acknowledged that CCTV footage does show
the police vehicle following the bike
but he said that when the Collision
occurred no police vehicle was in the
road so the police saying that they were
not part of this Collision he then went
on to talk about the trouble afterwards
15 officers he said were injured in the
disturbances and he wanted that
um phone footage or whatever members of
the public may have
um involving that those disturbances he
also said arrests were made and more
would follow but beyond that there was
not much from the police so not much
more from the police and he didn't take
uh questions